productive morning here in corridor
digital alright let's just get what goes
in at Nick
[Music]
so I misheard the thing going on in the
office where certain people when they
come over will attack us with nerf guns
all we have right now is little piddling
nerf guns to protect us and we need to
step up our game
who doesn't like making traps ever since
you watched home alone you've always
wanted to make a trap right well we're
going to build a nerf mind it's also
going to be a minefield before everybody
else who's in the game of life because
we're me saying the word mine a lot but
I'm not in the game and if you're
wondering what the heck the game of life
is anytime someone says the word mine
they have to do ten push-ups also once
you're in it you're in it for life so I
went online I did a bunch of research I
found a couple different models on
Thingiverse and there's one in
particular that I like it's obvious
guiding propter hoc it's a remix of
another design by ian great and an ant
on the red beard you have like a dart
holder in a like a plunger and a bunch
of rubber bands and a pin and when
somebody steps on a tripwire it pulls
the pinnacle and shoots all the darts so
I was actually the last one here in the
office last night working on this lookup
table pack that we're gonna be selling
on creative presets calm and I actually
set it up to print overnight so let's go
see how it turned out Nick was really
surprised it looks like you printed a
revolver when you break these yeah these
look very easy to break at my own nerve
pushers slightly don't crank on the
probably fine I think he liked all of
that yeah
you can see it when you look at the
bottom of the glass you can see where it
starts coming off so Ren just give us a
recap with it what does neko printed man
Niko has pursued a Nerf claim warm
alright piece 1 this is the trigger see
when I pull the bottom here you can see
it coming off not gonna do you think
it's gonna shatter no I'm not free to
gonna do like one of these things are
like misty business so do we have rubber
bands yes we do need rubber bands I
don't know if you have any the way this
works boom the nerf tights sit in this
thing and then this is loaded with
rubber bands and then there's a pin here
that will hold it in place when the pin
gets pulled that slams forward and it
launches all the nerves nerves all the
nurse
oh man where's all the darts go finish
putting this together here is that the
thing from your bedroom I'm moving out I
got it I got a new place so the first
time in 10 years are moving I've been
living in downtown in this very building
you were living on the other side yeah
in fact your bedrooms right there I want
a house in LA and it's a huge move and I
finally moved everything out and I'm
finding there's lots of things that I
had that I no longer need or use or
whatever and this gun happen to be one
of them so here's what happened the
entire time that Sam lived upstairs he
had my gun on his wall putting it back
in my hand yeah yeah I'm cleaning up the
place I'm like hey isn't this yours
and he's like thank gosh this is
actually a real gun it's super antique
it's a Lee Enfield it's like a British
gun yeah normally there's like a small
magazine or something that goes here but
you can see it's all sealed up right
here because this one was modified as
effectively a riot gun the chamber of
the weapon has been modified to shoot
410 shotgun shells with these very thin
tiny shotgun shells and it's only one
shot at a time you put the shell and
right there
it in and shoots so I've been wanting to
find a way to cast some fairly simple
gun props Ali Anfield this is like just
nondescript enough so that I could like
change a couple things around it and it
doesn't need to be perfect at all but
like once you paint and good for the
background cool old piece of history
almost most expensive rubber bands
between produce it goes between you hear
this little divot and here's a little
bit like this mm-hmm
like that oh man
it's armed right now I don't like to get
stabbed by the toothpick you won't hear
you might productive morning here in
corridor digital so we can get a bigger
like stickers and I'll go back in
further all right let's see how it goes
aim it at Nick I think like there's
gonna be a little bit more intense yeah
considering how much we need some more
bongos dude we're the few oh this is a
toothpick it's broken I think we need to
use a nail amigo I don't want a nail to
go flying into somebody's like leg we
can clip okay
[Music]
the easy answer to that is you can find
the best Lutz available at creator
presets comm actually they're not the
best that's available I would actually
give those to other luck of table pax
but the pretty dang good because we
worked on I'm here in corridor digital
some of our most popular videos we have
made presets of the color grades for you
guys so if you want to check them out we
have a 9 look-up tables for you over at
Crater presets calm go check them out
for yourself link in the description
below you go have a test one go
okay they were there they saw it it was
embarrassing there are nails work right
I've doubled the bongos the bongo ratio
is far far too low put your nail in
there god damn dude I'm gonna get the
punctured no dude this thing is about to
explode once I like dangerous like
whoever designed this tram is in the
same let me show you why this is
terrible flip this boards and it
releases the nail so the nails pushing
this way the nail itself gets pushed
forward at the same speed and velocity
in everything that the darts are being
pushed at I think the darts are going to
hit the wall with the amount of bongos
we've added I think the nail is gonna
make it halfway to the wall I think the
nail is gonna flop on the ground right
there anything that doesn't make it
halfway to the wall I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna
oh the nail went backwards it's so
unpredictable the nail was flung and
they'll Orange my god my Nerf darts and
nails I know so it's technically it's
yeah the Hasbro guys are gonna love this
these are all the pitches as you might
know we were in New York this past
weekend for the Madden 18 launch event
and you also might know that we got
Xboxes he said in the video let us know
if you think Carmichael should have it
for all the hard work he's been doing on
the channel or if we should give it away
and honestly I'm super impressed by how
many of you said Carmichael deserves the
Xbox
that's right Carmichael you are now the
proud owner of a brand new Xbox one LCS
10 for scorpions I thought it stood for
Scorpio or whatever it turns out it's
just slim so yeah I haven't had an Xbox
since high school
thank you everyone I have a video game
console I'm in the future how much line
do we want you want to do a test in here
just like on this shelf please the trip
it doesn't I'm saying you could write
and just see if it works there's like
right here perfect okay so you're gonna
arm it it was nothing shout out some
Horace Mann paper candle is gonna be a
little bit more safe here so you grab
the strings on the other side of this
door will just yell Wren we need battery
help it's a taut wire life is filled
with uncertainties sometimes you just
got to take a risk especially when you
can entertain other people in the
process
okay are we ready
it's so obvious turn the phone still
picking up that shine don't look at it I
mean if it doesn't work then try
something else I'm so bad at like
getting people to come in here though
there you go here just come with me as I
talk to like hey let me get Sam Sam come
in here Sam's gonna no no no I think
I'll just gonna lay here I'm not
standing there well first time you
stopped slowing down with Sam get
slowing down to its distraction nobody's
gonna talk about something
distract it we need training else in
here so we're all gonna focus on
something over here which will make
Ranma at the door will just burst in you
see here in you know what this thing is
hey red hey run you run
[Applause]
I feel betrayed but rest that was good I
didn't see that at all oh my god
did you get here with the nail they
tried to get me but problem this is baby
he tried to bring me in from the front
and then we realized we're all in here
like we have someone to focus look in
here you know yeah now the way you did
it work well like you might
[Laughter]
[Music]